Iron Man was awesome but everything
since has just been fine five movies in
how long can they keep doing the same
formula Avengers was so good guys this
is so good phase two has been so bad
everyone has Marvel fatigue I mean how
many movies is it the Avengers these
three has just been fine I don't know
not as good as faces one and two I think
we're all getting Marvel fatigue right
Avengers so good so good phases four and
five have been so mid except for
Spider-Man of course Avengers guys phase
seven has been so mid we are finally
just now getting Marvel Avengers Phase
10 was so mid I think people are finally
done with them but it's a Spider-Man
it's the Avengers I think we are finally
done with Marvel Avengers guys the year
is 2230 human race Seasons to exist all
human culture has been raised from the
planet from Shakespeare to 30 Rock
there's a great silence
Marvel releases Avengers 30